- So, you and I just met.
- Yes.
- And within 30 seconds you were willing
to give me your Netflix account.
- Yeah, sure.
- Let's do it.
(energetic, trumpet music)
- A recent study found
that 2/3 of Netflix users
share their account with someone else
with nearly 20 percent of
people sharing their account
with three people or more. Nuts.
HBO's chairman and CEO famously said that
"[Password sharing] has no
impact on the business."
So, password sharing, totally a thing.
Until recently, I had been using my
ex-roommate's ex-girlfriend's
Netflix password,
but I'm an adult, and it's
time to get my own passwords.
So, I hit the streets of
Hollywood to ask people,
"Yo, can I get your password?"
Do you have Netflix?
- Yes, indeed.
- Netflix, I have Hulu
Plus, I have Amazon Prime.
- Yes, well, it's not mine.
- It's not yours? What do you mean?
- It's a friend's account.
- You don't pay for it, you use...
- I don't pay for it, no.
- Is that your mother over there?
- Yeah.
- And you have no problem sharing
these passwords with your son for free?
- Not at all.
- We also share it with my brother.
- You share it with your brother?
- And my mom.
- And he doesn't pay anything.
- Not at all.
- Nothing, not a dime.
- Not a cent.
- Do you have a problem sharing
your password with people?
- No.
- It's no big deal, right? Password.
I'm wondering, do you
think I could get on that?
- My friend's?
- Yeah.
- Could you get on those accounts?
- I don't know you.
- You don't know me.
- No. I don't know you.
- I'm going to turn to you.
Would you give me the passwords?
- Are you going to pay?
- You're not paying. Why should I pay?
- But, I don't know your
mom, I don't know your dad.
- Do you want to call my mom?
Do you want to call my mom?
I will call my mom right now.
- Because, I mean, if
I'm going to give you
something personal like
that, my password...
- I should, like, take you out to dinner
in exchange or something.
- Exactly.
- Unfortunately, we
don't have it memorized.
Yeah, I think it's a pattern.
- Oh, I think I know. I think I know.
- You know it?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, if you wanted to.
- Yeah, I would love to. I don't have one.
Would you be willing to let me on it?
- Yeah.
- I mean if you really want it.
- Yeah, why not, right?
Because there are only
three people in our family.
- You have the information on you?
- Yeah.
- I gotta pen right here.
So you just let anyone on it.
- Yeah, I don't care.
- You think you remember it?
- Yeah.
- This is your friend's account?
- And your friend's not going to mind?
- There's like so many
people on this account,
I don't think she'll notice.
- How's your day going?
- Pretty good.
- There it is.
- Yeah, and then the password?
"Vodevodka.."
- So to be clear, we just met.
- Yeah.
- And you had no problem with this.
So, just a dude you met
from another country
that you'll never see again
ever again in your life.
- Yeah.
- Is that your wife?
- She thinks you've made a mistake.
- Alright, well this is great.
I've got one. I got a Netflix account.
- You can't show it to like the world.
- Well, I'll blur it,
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- I have Amazon Prime.
- You do have Amazon Prime.
So, I can like buy stuff
on this too, right?
I get free shipping?
- I guess so, yeah.
- Cool.
Do you have HBO Go?
- No.
- No? I'm trying to find
someone with HBO Go.
- I guess I could, but I'm not going to.
- No go?
- I think it's a no go. Sorry.
- Is it something I said?
- No, no it's not you, it's me.
- I've heard that one before.
Okay.
So we did it. We totally did it.
We were only out here for about an hour,
but we got a whole bunch
of Netflix passwords,
HBO and Hulu Plus a
little harder to come by.
Amazon Prime is possible but you
have to ask really nicely. So, yeah.
What did we learn here today?
Some people are very
protective of their passwords.
Most people don't give a (bleep).
If you want a password,
and you don't want to pay,
just go out on the street and
ask like I did. Pretty easy.
Thanks for watching.
(laughter)
It's so dumb.
Do you have Netflix?
- No I don't.
- You know, what about HBO Go?
- No.
- Hulu Plus?
- Crackle?
- No.
- You're worthless to me.
So, you have a password
code to your house?
- Yeah, because there's a
lock outside of my door.
- What's that number?
- It's a keypad.
- It's my address.
- So, if you want to break
into his house, it is...